the Idaho mom at the center of a
so-called doomsday plot that led to
murder is scheduled to be sentenced
later this year that mother you've heard
the name before Lori vallo day Bell was
convicted on Friday of killing her two
youngest children Tyler Ryan and J.J
valo and conspiring to kill the first
wife of her husband Chad dabell Chris
Van Cleef now has reaction to the
verdict
answer guilty an Idaho jury of seven men
and five women found Lori valo DeBell
guilty on all charges including the
first degree murders of her two youngest
children answer guilty while valo dabel
offered no visible reaction as the
verdicts were read we are elated with
this family members including
seven-year-old JJ's grandparents reacted
with emotion JJ
I love you I'm so relieved that Justice
was served tylie's Aunt Annie Cushing
but then there are those you know just
just those Quiet Moments of realizing
you know it doesn't ring
the victim's back during the five-week
trial the prosecution argued valo de
Bell's motives were money power and sex
Tyler JJ and Tammy can't tell us what
happened
that their bodies do prosecutors called
nearly 60 Witnesses the defense rested
without calling a single one but painted
her as a victim of her husband Chad a
doomsday cult leader she's following
Chad
she thinks Chad is following Jesus
but he's not a source close to the trial
says valo dabel was unhappy her lawyers
tried to place blame for the murders on
her husband who will be tried separately
and while Lori can only face up to life
in prison Chad dabel if convicted he
could get the death penalty her husband
Chad's lawyers were there were listening
to her defense attorneys blaming him for
all the criminal misconduct that
certainly will be part of his trial Chad
davil has pleaded not guilty his wife
will face sentencing in the coming
months for CBS mornings I'm Chris Van
Cleave in Boise Idaho